i served time in federal prison which  turned out to be the best thing for me i  got clean i rediscovered my passion  then my dad broke you out exactly to  kill you exactly  but just as his men  were tying me up for my execution i  launched into a performance of my  macbeth whence is that knocking away  duncan with their knocking i wish though  because they couldn't get enough of it  i've been doing weekly ghosts for lads  ever since  so you're like is jester i can give you  a quick preview if you like uncle and  uncle now thank you trevor i think we're  okay  right now we really just need to find a  way to  what the hell what the [ __ ] oh oh what  is that  oh whoo what's what  i can see you  you're real  all this time i thought it was  hallucinating him oh this is such fab  news  where's his face  he's a bit sensitive about that  uh  uh  you